okay in this
second part I'm gonna start with linear
equations a times X equal B and you see
actually the first really the good
starting point is a times x equals zero
so are there any any solutions to the
matrix any combinations of the columns
that give 0 any solutions to a times x
equals 0
now I'm multiplying the matrix a by a
vector X in a in a in the way you'll
know I take rows of x times it's called
a dot product row of X row sorry rows of
a times X so I have a row of numbers and
X is a column of numbers I multiply
those numbers and add to get dot product
and I'm wondering can I get 0 for each
is every is every row so having a 0
there is telling me gee in geometry that
that Row is perpendicular orthogonal to
that column if a row dot product with a
column gives me a 0 then then in
n-dimensional space that row is
perpendicular 90-degree angle to that
that column X so I'm looking to see is
there are there any vectors X that are
perpendicular to all the rows
that's what ax equals 0 is asking for oh
and that's what I've just said right
there I've used the word orthogonal
that's more of a high-level word than
perpendicular so I'll stay with that
sound a little cooler okay and now we
can also look at that transpose oh do
you know what the transpose of a matrix
is I take those rows and flip the matrix
so that those rows become the columns
and the columns of a become the rows of
a transpose so I'll look at a transpose
x I'll call it Y for the new problem a
transpose Y is all zeros
and then the null space will be any
vector any solutions any Y that's
perpendicular to the rows of a transpose
so I would need hours couple of hours of
teaching to develop this properly
because we're talking here about the
fundamental theorem of linear algebra
which tells me that the vectors in the
null space like that our perpendicular
to the vectors these guys are that's the
row space oh but maybe I have told you
I've said that from this equation that
tells you the geometry that the row
vectors are perpendicular to the X
vector the thing in the null space so X
is there the rows are there and they're
perpendicular now if I transpose the
matrix doesn't remember that means
exchanging rows and columns so I have a
new matrix new size even it will the
same but it's a matrix the same will be
true for it the the the rows become the
columns and the solutions to the new
equation with a transpose go in that
space so so that then that little
perpendicular sign is reminding us of
the geometry so rows perpendicular to
the X's columns perpendicular to the Y's
that's the best I finally saw the right
way to say that so I have two pairs and
I know how big those each of those four
things are those are the four
fundamental subspaces to null spaces to
two solution spaces with zero null means
0 so the these X's are in the null space
because of that 0 those are the ends and
then this is the column space and the
row space so we got four spaces
altogether two pairs and now you get to
see the big picture of linear algebra we
the four fundamental subspaces do their
thing there you go you can die happy now
it says the row space is there those are
rows of the matrix independent rows of
the matrix that's why I don't put in all
the rows there are M rows but I only put
in independent ones so that might be a
smaller number our our the rank and here
are the solutions the guys
perpendicularly this is the rows of the
matrix these are the vectors
perpendicular to it these are the
columns of the matrix these are the
vectors perpendicular to the columns you
see it's just a natural splitting of the
of the whole spaces of vectors into two
pieces and two pieces and I think of the
matrix a when it multiplies stuff there
it gives stuff here when a multiplies a
vector X you get something you get a
combination of the columns that was the
very very first slide a times X is a
combination of the columns and then we
look at some X's if there are any that
where a times X gives 0 and those there
is 0 right there
ok ok so that's the big picture and I'll
just point to another little little
point that's hiding in this picture you
see that little symbol there that little
thing and it's also here what that means
is that those guys are perpendicular to
these and these are perpendicular to
these so we have four subspaces two
pairs two perpendicular pairs and that's
when you get the idea of knowing what
they mean knowing how to find them at
least for a small matrix you've got the
heart of linear algebra part one this is
the first half of linear algebra okay
I'll just see what else there is
oh here oh well this is this is a
another comment I have hardly told you
how to multiply two matrices the usual
way is
rose times columns but linear algebra
being always interesting there's another
way that I happen to like columns times
rows now there is a column times a row
now column times a row we've seen that
once for for that rank one matrix do you
remember I said that those rank one
matrix one column times one row are the
building blocks well here is the
building those are n of those blocks a
column times a row or column times a row
and here is a reminder of oh we've only
oh we're coming up to a güell Lu the
first one get on with it
professor Strang okay okay now we're
solving equations now we're gonna get L
times U so right so there's two
equations in two unknowns solved in high
school and how do you remember how
that's the whole point if I take twice
that equation so it's 4x plus 6y equals
14 and subtract from this one then I get
an easy equation for only Y by itself so
that's what I did that's called
elimination I eliminated this 4x it's
gone it's 2 times that right that's why
I chose to multiply it by 2 then 1/2 x
times this gives me 4 X's when I
subtract it it's gone and I'm left with
1 y equal 1 so I know the answer y equal
1 and then I go backwards 2 X equal 2
because 2 X plus this is now 3 equals 7
2 X is 4 X is 2 and the real point about
linear algebra done right is that all
those steps can be expressed as a
breakup
another way to break up the matrix a
into a lower triangular matrix
you see that that matrix is triangular
it's lower triangular and this one is
upper triangular so those are called L&U
yep yep so what we did here is expressed
by that matrix multiplication you really
want to express everything in the end as
multiplying a couple of matrices then
you know exactly where you are
so that's the that's the idea of
elimination and and now we only were
doing a two by two matrix you remember
our little matrix was pathetic
two three four seven that was our matrix
a we can't stop there
so linear algebra it goes on to matrix
of any size and this is the way to find
the triangular factor L and the upper
triangular factor you that would need
more time so all I want to say is when
you're doing elimination solving
equations then in the back of your mind
or in the back page you are producing an
L matrix lower and a u matrix upper so
that so yeah let me see yeah here we see
them the Lommel matrix is all zeros
above the U matrix is all zeros below
and that's what is really happening so
that's what that's what computer system
totally focuses on okay that's the first
slide of a new part so I'll stop here
and coming back to orthogonal vectors
good